Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
De tan obvio que es
prácticamente proverbial.
No puedes deshervir un huevo.
Bueno, resulta que
se puede, más o menos.
El efecto de la energía térmica
sobre las moléculas del huevo
puede deshacerse
con energía mecánica.
Los huevos están hechos
mayoritariamente de agua y proteínas.
Las proteínas aparecen
plegadas de manera compleja
y se mantienen unidas por
enlaces químicos débiles.
El calor altera su conformación
lo que permite a las proteínas
desplegarse, desenrollarse,
y moverse libremente.
Este proceso se llama
desnaturalización.
Las proteínas recién liberadas
chocan contra sus vecinas
y empiezan a formar
nuevos enlaces entre sí,
más y más, a medida
que el calor aumenta,
hasta que, al final, están tan enredadas
que se convierten en una masa sólida,
un huevo duro.
Ese entrelazamiento parece
permanente, pero no lo es.
Según un concepto químico
llamado principio de
reversibilidad microscópica,
todo lo que sucede, como el enredo
fibroso de las proteínas del huevo
es teóricamente un proceso reversible.
Pero añadir más calor solo
enreda más las proteínas,
mientras que refrigerarlas
solo las congela,
así que el truco está
en centrifugarlas
increíblemente rápido.
No estoy bromeando.
Así es como funciona.
Primero, los científicos disuelven
las claras de huevo cocidas en agua
con la ayuda de una sustancia
química llamada urea,
una pequeña molécula
que actúa como lubricante,
y que recubre las largas
cadenas de proteínas,
lo que les facilita deslizarse
una al lado de la otra.
Luego centrifugan esta
solución en un tubo de cristal
a una velocidad vertiginosa
de 5000 rotaciones por minuto,
lo que hace que la solución
se transforme en una película fina.
Esta es la parte clave.
La solución que se halla
más cerca de la pared
gira más rápido que la solución
más cercana al centro del tubo.
Esta diferencia de velocidad
crea tales tensiones
que las proteínas se estiran
y se contraen repetidamente
hasta que finalmente,
se rompen bajo presión,
vuelven a su forma
inicial y se quedan así.
En el momento en el cual
la centrifugadora deja de girar,
la clara de huevo está de vuelta
en su estado original, sin hervir.
Esta técnica funciona con
todo tipo de proteínas.
Las proteínas más grandes con cadenas
más complejas son más resistentes
así que los científicos conectan
un cordón de plástico a un extremo
lo que genera tensión adicional
y tiende a doblar la proteína primero.
Este método 'de deshervir' no funcionará
con un huevo entero en su cáscara
ya que la solución tiene que
girar en un recipiente cilíndrico.
Pero las aplicaciones van mucho más allá
de 'descocinar' el desayuno.
Muchos medicamentos
contienen proteínas
extremadamente caras,
en parte porque conforman
agregados complejos
al igual que las claras de huevo cocidas
y que tienen que ser
desenredadas y vueltas a plegar
antes de poder hacer su trabajo.
Esta técnica de rotación
tiene el potencial
de ser un método más fácil,
más barato y más rápido
que otros métodos para
volver a plegar proteínas,
lo que puede permitir
que nuevos medicamentos
estén disponibles para más
gente, más rápidamente.
Y hay una cosa más a tener en cuenta
antes de intentar
"descocinar" la comida.
Hervir un huevo es en realidad
un proceso de cocción inusual
porque a pesar de que
se cambia la forma
en la cual las proteínas están
conformadas y conectadas entre sí,
su identidad química
no cambia realmente.
La mayoría de los tipos
de cocción se parecen más
a la famosa reacción de Maillard,
donde los cambios químicos
convierten los azúcares y las proteínas
en delicioso caramelo crujiente,
algo mucho más
difícil de deshacer.
Así que, a lo mejor,
podrás deshervir un huevo,
pero lamento decir que
todavía no puedes desfreirlo...